Biddeford the little white town but too
often it's actually the little gray town
and we want to do something about it
there are too many neglected or
forgotten spaces across Biddeford which
we want to see come alive again turning
the center of Biddeford into a little
green town the Biddeford town center
partnership is working with the Friends
of the earth on a crowdfunding campaign
we're looking to raise five thousand
pounds to employ a community gardener
for a year and to buy seeds trees plants
and planters to make the town center
green and making an attractive place to
be and to spend time but we also wanted
to be fun and where possible edible
imagine just picking a few strawberries
and the smiles that will bring fancy an
apple well herself but make sure there's
one left for someone else - how about
some herbs we're working with the
Biddeford sustainability group who took
over the home stone carpark in May yes
it looks love now with bees everywhere
herbs to pick and color all over the
place but it's also built a community
around the work think up might be
possible across a town if we raise the
money for a community gardener to
support work and build more communities
so we're keen to get the community
involved if you've got ideas for places
and Town Center to turn green or want to
be involved please get in touch - a
little green town on Facebook and
Twitter and please please share and
pledged to make Biddeford ten times
greener